comme une répétition avant le nouvel an
les forces de l'ordre étaient mobilisés
ce jeudi 30 décembre pour contrôler les
passants après 20h sur plusieurs axes
yvelinois c'est pas la prévention c'est
une application stricte des mesures
liées au couvre-feu
nous sommes là pour en assurer les
contrôles et éviter les rassemblements
sur la voie publique parce que bien
évidemment ligne de mire pour le 31 nous
voulons éviter les violences urbaines
la grande majorité des personnes
rentrant du travail les agents vérifient
que leurs attestations professionnelle
soit en règle
environ 150 agents du côté de la police
nationale et 150 militaires de la
gendarmerie sont déployés ce soir
naturellement demain soir encore le sens
des dispositions plus importante encore
seront prises on doublera les effectifs
un dispositif plus important le soir du
réveillon pour dissuader coûte que coûte
les rassemblements en trop grand nombre
regarde l'enjeu sanitaire important la
fermeté sera de rigueur
bien qu'il soit interdit pour les
représentants de la loi de rentrer dans
les habitations
nous pouvons évidemment relever tout ce
qui est à paj doc turne il s'agit sont
des soirées festives improvisé donc nous
nous ferons le nécessaire à partir du
monde se déplace où elles ont lieu jeudi
en plein air pour verbaliser donc les
les participants et voir si
effectivement non que nous pouvons
identifier des organisateurs dont les
noms seront donnés évidemment à la
justice
une opération mise en place tout au long
de la nuit du 31 qui concernera cent
mille policiers et des gendarmes partout
en france